[MUSIC PLAYING]
URS HOLZLE: Hi.
Good morning, everyone,
and welcome to Google Cloud
Platform Live here
in San Francisco.
But I also want to welcome
every one of you who's
watching from our offices in
Seattle, New York, and London.
And also from the many viewing
parties, online viewing
parties, all around the world.
So I'm Urs Holzle,
and I'm responsible
for the technical
infrastructure at Google.
My team, which includes
thousands of engineers,
builds and runs
the infrastructure
that all of Google-- and now
the Google Cloud Platform--
is built on.
So the data centers, the
networks, the servers,
and the software
systems on top of that.
Now I started in 1999
to work with Google,
and it's really
gratifying for me
to see that this platform, this
super-efficient and scalable
and fast, worldwide platform
is now available for everyone
to use, to deploy applications
to pretty much any device,
any user, pretty much
anywhere in the world.
Now, the Google Cloud
Platform is a central part
of our infrastructure
development.
And we're investing
heavily in it
to make it as great a
platform for external users
as it has been for
internal users at Google.
So we're laying the
groundwork for years and years
of improvements and innovation.
And while we already
have a strong platform,
these are the early days, so
you can expect a lot more.
There's many things that are
still hard in a platform.
But we see a clear path to
making developers phenomenally
more productive.
And build applications.
They really take advantage
of our platform and all
the services that it has to use.
Be that storage, compute,
or higher level things
like maps or speech
recognition or translation.
Google is really committed
to the Google Cloud Platform.
And as you'll see today, we'll
be introducing new features
at a pretty rapid pace.
So today, I want to
spend my time with you
on three particular
themes or topics.
First, a quick look
back at what we've
done in the last
12 months or so.
But then second, while we've
already accomplished a lot,
I want to talk
about the challenges
that people still
face in the cloud.
There's a lot of ways in
which the promise of the cloud
isn't fully met yet.
And we see that as
a major opportunity.
So we want to make developers
much more productive.
And so in the third
part I'll talk
about how we are
going to do that.
Today we're announcing new
functionality, new pricing,
that will help you developers
be more productive, more
economical, and hopefully
have more fun while you do it.
So first, let's look at a few
highlights from last year.
12 months ago-- it's
actually hard to think back
12 months ago because our world
was so much different back
then, and we changed
so much since then.
So obviously at I/O last
May, here in San Francisco,
we introduced Compute
Engine, so the ability
to run VMs in
Google data centers.
And we introduced them
with a few cool features,
such as large consistent
disks and per minute billing,
so you only pay for the
minutes that you actually use.
We also introduce that at the
same time, PHP for App Engine.
PHP, obviously, one of the
most popular languages, and PHP
for App Engine having been one
of the most popular features
of all time-- feature
requests of all time.
Then in August, we showed
you Layer 3 load balancing.
And you might
remember, in November
when we demoed it,
that it can reach
a million requests per
second, from a cold start,
in five seconds with no need
to preprovision or warm up
anything.
So even a 1.0 product,
like load balancing,
is actually pretty
mature and pretty stable.
And the reason for that is that
it's based on the same code
base that powers load
balancing for Google.com.
You're going to see that a
lot from our infrastructure.
Then in December, we
put Compute Engine
into GA-- General Availability--
and introduced a few more
new features there that
I'll talk about in a minute.
On the data side,
we also did a lot.
We introduced Cloud Datastore,
our fully managed, NoSQL data
store that scales to pretty much
anything you can throw at it.
Based on our very own BigTable,
the system that actually
started the NoSQL revolution,
we have offline disk import,
encryption at rest, native
connections for Cloud SQL.
So one example of where
we're following open
API so that you can
use all the tools that
come with an ecosystem
that's been built up
around these APIs.
So something we're really
committed to in a Google Cloud.
Many improvements
to persistent disks.
And then SQL went GA,
general availability,
just last month with 99.95%
SLA, larger instance types,
and encryption of
all data at rest.
But we didn't stop there.
We also introduced many
improvements to BigQuery.
So for example, now you can
join huge tables with ease
and really do big data
computing at scale.
We have dedicated
memcache that, again,
scales to pretty much
arbitrary size and load.
Lots of other updates.
Mobile backend starter for iOS.
So now on both
Android and in iOS,
you can build the backend
for your application
with very little effort.
And cloud endpoints,
like you do RESTful APIs,
for your own applications
with little programming.
And just last month, we
announced HIPAA support,
adding to the long
list of certifications
that our cloud already has.
So that's great.
And I want to spend a little
bit more time on one feature.
Just one of these--
and we couldn't really
mention all of them--
but one of them
is live migration
as we announced.
So when Compute Engine
went to GA last month--
or last December, it came
with a unique feature
called live migration.
Now why is that important?
Well, as a cloud provider,
you're faced with a dilemma.
Because you can either have an
up-to-date infrastructure-- you
know, patch your
operating systems,
upgrade, introduce
new features, hands-on
at a rapid pace-- or you
can provide long-running VMs
to your users.
But you can't really do both.
Because if you apply a
security patch to the OS,
in the underlying
host OS, and then
have to reboot the machine, the
VM can't really survive that.
But live migration
solves this dilemma
and lets us provide both.
And to show you
how it works, I'd
like to introduce Chris Elliott
to give you a demo-- here
you are, Chris--
of live migration.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: So in order
to demonstrate how seamless
live migration is
for our customers,
we built this sample
application here,
which is going to live stream an
HD video from an instance that
is undergoing live migration.
This instance is physically
moving around in our data
centers while we're live
streaming this video.
And this happens blazingly fast.
I'm going to walk
you through what
you can expect to see here.
This instance down here,
VOD 1, is the instance
that'll be streaming the video.
And once we start
live migration,
you'll see a spinning wheel
appear on that instance.
Then it'll briefly
flash yellow, and that
is when the switch happens
to the new physical host.
So without further delay
here, I have a terminal window
into my instance, and I'm
going to start a script that
is keeping an eye out for
a signal we send to the VM
when we're running
live migration.
This script is then going to
fire off to the App Engine
app you saw earlier
and update that UI.
So, we're good there.
Let's jump back over to the UI.
And I have an engineer
waiting by in Seattle
to simulate a physical hardware
failure, such as a power
supply overheating on
this current hardware
where it's hosted.
And that will then
trigger live migration.
So let's get this started.
And so we should
see, very shortly,
that this VOD 1 instance
will start live migrating
once she runs the tool.
And we'll wait for it
to start live migrating
until we start
streaming the video.
And here we go,
1080P video streaming
while this instance is
undergoing live migration.
And so this is currently
syncing the two states
of those physical
machines, getting
ready to make that switch
over to the new machine.
And it should happen
any second now,
because it's amazing how
quickly-- and there it is!
And now we're on a
new physical machine.
That is live migration, that
is how quickly we can migrate.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
And there's two points I
wanted to highlight here.
One is, it's amazing--
it fundamentally
changes how developers
build on virtual machines.
We have added
intelligence to that layer
so we can now proactively
live migrate you
around hardware issues.
So you're always going to have
a high performant, consistent
system.
Similarly, it allows us to
upgrade under the covers
so that you always have
the safest and most
secure environment to
run your workloads on.
And the other aspect here is
this is completely transparent.
That is the real magic.
We built this demo on
signals that are available,
but you shouldn't even
really care about this
when you're running.
During development
and testing, we
had a test cluster
with customers
running large
production workloads.
And they were trying to find
any performance hiccups to find
when live migration happened.
We ended up getting email at
the end of the day asking hey,
are you not doing
live migration?
What's happening?
When in reality, we moved
them back and forth 10 times
that day.
It really is seamless fast.
The instance is
exactly the same.
Same IP, same
configuration, and you
really don't need to know
about it live migrating at all.
And at the end of the
day, the only thing
that actually tells
you it migrated
is a little note in
your operations log.
That's it.
And this is how we can--one of
the ways we can provide high
performance computing with
Compute Engine and give
developers the consistency
they expect from Google.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
URS HOLZLE: Thank you, Chris.
So you can see, even
though our VMs may
look similar to
other VMs, there's
really a lot of innovation
under the covers
that make it a unique platform.
Now let's take a look
at what kind of adoption
we've been seeing.
We now have over 4.75
active applications
running in a Google
Cloud Platform,
continuing the strong trend
that we've seen last year.
And App Engine alone gets over
28 billion front end requests
per day, every day.
So for comparison, that's more
than 10 Wikipedias-- worldwide
Wikipedias-- just for
App Engine content.
On the back end with
Datastore, the numbers
are even more staggering.
Datastore currently serves
6.3 trillion requests per day.
Now trillion is really a
very, very large number,
so it's hard to put
that in relation.
One way to visualize it is as 30
operations per day, every day,
for every person
living on Earth.
Just in Datastore transactions.
And finally, we've
been working a lot
on being not just the fastest
cloud but also the most
cost effective cloud.
And it's great to
see this starting
to be recognized in the press.
"InfoWorld," for example,
reported that we ran
their benchmarks faster
than any other cloud
and less expensively
than any other cloud.
So who is on Google Cloud today?
Now our customers range
from small startups
to public companies to
large consumer services,
really all across the board.
Some of them are running their
entire business on the Google
Cloud, and others
are taking advantage
of just certain parts
of their workload
that fit really
well into our cloud.
So Costco, for example,
runs their entire websites
in several countries
on the cloud platforms.
Citrix runs their
developer platform.
Netflix, Zulily.
TiVo uses our storage.
Airbnb and Zillow use
our translate API.
Phillips is developing-- or is
deploying their new light bulb
using the Google Cloud.
And we power Khan Academy,
optimizing millions
of other websites.
And Wicks for example,
or WebFilings,
are two businesses that are
entirely based on Google Cloud.
So, last month, we
traveled to Ames, Iowa,
to visit WebFilings.
A company that you
may not have heard of,
but that in three years captured
60% of the Fortune 500 market
for financial disclosures.
And so, let's have
a look of how they
do it using the
Google Cloud Platform.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We hear all the time when
we talk about WebFilings
that people are surprised that
we're based in Ames, Iowa.
People do expect us to
be in Silicon Valley
because we're very much a
Silicon Valley type of company.
At WebFilings, we
build applications
that help companies build
their financial reports.
-WebFilings started
the summer of 2008.
We had eight engineers in one
of the founders' basement.
We launched our
product early in 2010.
We grew very rapidly.
We have 2,000 corporate
customers now.
60% of the Fortune 500 use
our flagship product, WDesk,
all running on Google
Cloud Platform.
-Building on Google
Cloud Platform
allowed us to spend money on
infrastructure as we needed it
and not have to
make a big upfront
investment in data
centers and servers.
So, as we were growing,
we were able to invest
in customer service.
A couple of days ago, I just
looked at the dashboard,
and I was like, we're
serving a bunch more traffic,
and I didn't even know
that that happened.
Cloud Platform scales on demand.
I don't have to spend my
time thinking about it.
And it gave the company
a sense of confidence
with Google running the
data centers that it would
be a secure place to put
prerelease financial data.
-Cloud Platform offers
us a variety of services.
App Engine provides us
with dynamically scalable
application servers.
Compute Engine allows us to run
standard off-the-shelf services
and components.
We leverage cloud
storage because that
allows us to efficiently
store and serve large binary
blobs of data.
BigQuery allows us to
process and analyze
large volumes of
data in real time.
-Being in a company
that's growing this fast
is really the experience
of a lifetime,
because we've been able to
build on really cool platforms
like the Cloud Platform.
And seeing your
product take off and be
successful in the marketplace
is an incredible experience.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
URS HOLZLE: All right,
so WebFilings is just
one of the many companies that
I mentioned that really base
their entire business
on the Google Cloud.
And obviously they're
all about enterprise.
So let's look at another company
that's all about the consumer.
Now we've all heard
about Snapchat.
A small team of
engineers, they have
built one of the most
popular applications
on the internet today.
And it's been fun for
us to partner with them.
And so I'm excited today
to welcome Bob Murphy, CTO
and co-founder of
Snapchat to the stage
so we can hear their
story first hand.
Sorry, Bobby.
Please come up.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so I'm curious
how you actually got
started with both the idea and
sort of the infrastructure.
What led you there?
BOBBY MURPHY: Evan and I
got started on Snapchat
in summer of 2011.
Basically understood
that visual content
was the most engaging,
interesting form of content
that there was and
wanted to create a way
to enable that to be a
means of communication
rather than a piece of content
around which communication
actually happened.
So that was the initial
concept behind Snapchat.
We launched on Google
App Engine because I've
used App Engine a couple
times for some small projects
and found it was super
easy to get up and running.
And at the time, obviously
our biggest priority
was to get a product
in the hands of users
in the real world as
quickly as possible.
And so I turned
again, to App Engine,
something that I was
very familiar with.
A platform that very
easily abstracts away
a lot of the complexities
of building, deploying a web
backend into the real world.
And I think at the
time, App Engine
was actually still in preview.
So we took a chance
on a new platform.
But I was fairly confident,
given Google's reputation
as a very strong
infrastructure company,
that anything we
built on App Engine
would eventually
scale if we needed to.
URS HOLZLE: And it did.
So, can you tell us a
little bit about how
that platform supported your
launch of more recent features,
like the Stories feature that
you launched just recently?
BOBBY MURPHY: Yeah, absolutely.
It's actually been very
surprising for us--
and like, super fortunate--
to see Cloud Platform grow
its feature set almost
perfectly in sync
with our own feature needs.
It's actually funny looking
at the timeline earlier
because we've taken
advantage of almost all
of those product offerings
almost immediately
upon them being released
to the general public.
So around the time that we
were launching Stories, which
was fall of last
year, App Engine
was great for our
core application,
but we were looking
for something
a little more flexible
to support the Stories
architecture, which
currently uses Redis
on a huge cluster of
Compute Engine instances.
And so we were looking
around, and that
was exactly when Compute Engine
launched to the general public.
And so-- along with
outgoing socket connections
from App Engine
front end-- so it
was actually perfect
timing for us,
and that's worked and
scaled tremendously well.
URS HOLZLE: So you're
running lots of Redis today?
BOBBY MURPHY: We are.
Yeah, we've got 256 master
nodes and two slaves
per each with a
Twemproxy cluster
in front and Google load
balancers in front of that.
URS HOLZLE: And so,
obviously, that all
came with a huge amount
of growth, right?
Not just in the beginning,
but actually it's
really an amazing thing.
The growth has just
been keeping up.
So how have we helped you?
I hope we have helped you.
BOBBY MURPHY:
Yeah, you guys have
seen the growth first hand.
Absolutely, so the
biggest benefit
is just the fact
that we can focus
much less on maintaining
infrastructure and much more
on building new infrastructure
to support the features
and product developments
that we need.
In fact, actually, Tim-- one
of our VPs of engineering--
just last week told me one
of his biggest surprises
at joining Snapchat
was that not having
to deal with the operational
headache and complexity
that he was expecting
and you would expect
from a company at our growth
rate and at our current scale.
So yeah, the biggest
benefit is just the fact
that we can focus less on
maintaining infrastructure
and much more on
building new stuff.
URS HOLZLE: And so, as
far as I understand,
you still don't have an
operations team, really.
BOBBY MURPHY: No, not really.
We're at about 25 engineers now.
Little bit of operational
work here and there.
But for the most
part, everyone's
focused on new
feature development.
URS HOLZLE: Cool.
So if you had a piece
of advice for anyone
out there who wants to build
the next Snapchat on the Google
Cloud Platform, how
should they go about it?
BOBBY MURPHY: Yeah,
I would just say
it's a super easy
platform to use.
We got started on
the App Engine, which
is amazingly simple to use, and
has scaled tremendously well.
I've been absolutely
impressed and very surprised
that it's scaled
as well as it has.
Certainly thought early on that
the kind of traditional notion
of you build on
a hosted solution
and you reach a certain size
at which you have to move off,
I think is fading, and Google
is paving the way there.
And so, what's great
about App Engine
and Cloud Platform in
general is that you
get that kind of up
front ease of use
with the added comfort of
knowing that whatever you're
building, if it needs to, will
eventually scale ad infinitum.
URS HOLZLE: Great.
Let's go to infinity and beyond.
Thanks Bobby.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So people like you
make it look easy.
Just a small team building an
insanely popular application
and just scaling just like that.
Now, even though there are
success stories like this,
as I mentioned a little
bit earlier, building
an app in the cloud is still
harder than it should be.
Because you have to
spend a lot of times
worrying about things
that you shouldn't really
have to worry about.
So too many things
to think about.
Too many trade-offs to make.
And too much work that's
not really related
to building your app.
Let's look at a few of them.
Consider pricing.
Pricing is still
way too complex.
It may seem cheap
by comparison with
your on-premise alternatives.
But there's still a lot
of room for it to go down.
And moreover, it
seems like you need
a Ph.D. to figure
out the best options.
Should you use on
demand instances
that are flexible or
cheaper reserved instances?
And should you pre-pay,
and if so, how much?
And for how long are
you going to use them,
and how much are you
going to use them
over the next year, et cetera?
How do you optimize your
cost versus your performance?
Way too much complexity there.
And often, developers
also are forced
to make design trade-offs.
Like Bobby just
mentioned, should you
get started really
quickly but then
risk having to rewrite
everything down the road?
Or should you build
something scalable
but be less productive?
Now we want cloud to
be easier, and so we
want to solve both
of these problems.
And today, in the
next 10 minutes or so,
I'll talk about that.
So first, let's
start with pricing.
And the chart here
illustrates the typical VM
in sort of the average industry
cloud over the last five years
or so.
So prices have been
falling by about 6% to 8%
per year, which is pretty nice.
But hardware prices,
during the same five years,
have been falling by
about 20% to 30% a year.
So the cost of the underlying
components, CPUs, RAM, flash,
disk-- has been
falling much faster.
Because they've been
following Moore's law,
and cloud prices haven't.
And so over time, that's opened
quite a gap over several years.
Easily a factor of two
between the two curves.
And we don't think that this
gap should really exist.
Because while the two
curves can't be identical,
because the VM price also
includes not just the capital
expenditures, but also the
cost of running the VM, power,
space, maintenance,
administration, and so on.
But the gap should be
nowhere this large.
We think the two curves should
be much closer together.
And today we're
taking a big step
to bringing them much closer.
And we think over the
next two or three years
that they will be
even closer still.
So I'll now describe
how we do this.
First, we will have on demand
price reductions that make our
on demand pricing
incredibly attractive.
So Moore's Law at
work, basically.
And then second,
I'll show you how
you get additional
discounts that traditionally
come with reserved instances.
But with no upfront payment,
no commitment, and no lock-in.
And together, these
two changes bring
you industry leading
performance, price
performance-- really by far--
without the complexity that's
common in the industry.
Yes.
Just wait for the details.
So let's get started with the
on demand price reductions.
So we start with immediate
price reductions that bring our
on demand pricing to
where it really should be,
given Moore's Law.
On Compute Engine,
we're reducing prices
by 32% across the board
and in all regions.
So now our on demand price
is lower than the three year
reserve price of
most other providers.
But that's not all.
In storage, we price all storage
now at a consistent $0.026
per gigabyte.
No matter whether they
use it for App Engine,
or for Compute Engine.
And no matter whether you
store a gigabyte or a petabyte.
So for most users, that's a
68% decrease in storage cost
and our lower cost,
DRA alternative
that gives you the same
durability with a little bit
less availability, is $0.02.
So now they're more than
20% cheaper than that.
But that's not all.
On BigQuery, we're also reducing
the on demand prices by 85%.
So now BigQuery is really
accessible to everyone.
And in BigQuery, we're
going one step further
because our largest
customers have told us
that they want
predictable throughput
for their applications.
And so now, you can
analyze any amount
of data with a chosen
level of throughput
in 5 gigabyte per second
increments at a fixed price.
So you can-- and
you just tell us
how much performance you want.
what throughput do you want,
and we just provision everything
for you.
So you don't have
to worry about what
hardware resources you need
to pick, and how many of them,
and where, etc.
So with other cloud providers,
or on-premise solutions,
if you wanted 5
gigabytes per second
of query throughputs--
so gigabytes per second,
not megabytes per second-- you'd
pay about $80,000 per month.
And you'd have to worry about
picking the right configuration
and everything.
So with Compute Engine and
BigQuery, this is just $20,000
a month.
So 75% deduction.
And on top of the
predictable performance,
you also get on
demand elasticity
so that when your needs really
spike, you can go even higher.
So together, we are really
resetting the price curve
in a cloud to
where it should be.
And this isn't a one time
step, this is a philosophy.
The price trend of
virtualized hardware
should follow the price
trend of real hardware.
So it should follow Moore's Law.
And with the Google
Cloud Platform,
you're going to
see exactly that.
Now one more problem with
pricing is really that
it's-- as I mentioned--
it's too complicated.
So now we've lowered the
prices, but the original dream
of the cloud-- and
the original promise--
was that you could
get elastic capacity.
So on demand capacity, you
only pay for what you use.
You don't have to preprovision,
you don't have to commit,
and it's cheaper than
anything you can do yourself.
Now, the industry
hasn't really evolved
towards that simple concept.
In fact, along the way, things
have gotten more complicated.
Much more complicated.
Here's a graph that shows the
total cost of a typical VM
over three years given
different pricing choices.
So you can see that there's a
huge difference, a factor of 10
difference, between the
lowest and the highest price,
depending on what
price plan you choose.
And it's the same resource.
So for the same
resource, you can
pay 10 times more if
you don't pay attention.
So the question is, should
you use on demand instances,
or should you prepay to
get a reserved instance?
And if so, how much do you
prepay, and for how long
do you want to
reserve this instance?
And you have to
guess how much am I
going to actually use
this VM for the next year?
Or the next three years?
This is not simple, on
demand, elastic computing.
This requires a Ph.D. in
finance to kind of get right.
And so either you have
someone on your team
who spends a lot of time
worrying about this.
Or, you're probably
paying too much.
Or both.
So this isn't completely crazy.
Reserved instances
actually have a purpose,
because they try to
reward you for having
a predictable,
sustained workload.
And of course you
should get a discount
for having a sustained workload.
But we think that you
should get that discount
with no upfront price, with
no upfront expenditures.
With no contract, no lock-in,
and just no complexity.
So how do we do that?
I'll show you how.
Today we're introducing
sustained-use discounts.
We want you to be
rewarded automatically
for having sustained usage
without you requiring
to preplan.
So we're moving the burden
of planning from you to us.
How does this work?
Well, here's an example.
We start with the low rates
that we just announced.
So rates that are lower
there anywhere else.
But once you use a VM for
more than 25% of the month,
your price starts dropping.
So every additional
minute becomes cheaper.
So that means that if you
have a 24/7 workload that you
use for an entire month,
like a database instance,
then in effect, you get a 53%
discount over today's prices.
And what's even better,
you don't-- this price,
this discount applies to all
instances of a certain type
in a region.
So even if you have a VM
that you restart frequently,
as long as that VM in
aggregate is used more than 25%
of the month, you
get that discount.
So simple, easy
pricing that gives you
a discount based on your
actual usage with no commitment
upfront.
And remember that our pricing
already has simplicity
built in in all kinds
of other places.
So you have per minute
billing, where you only
pay for the minutes
you actually use.
And you have linear scaling
of prices across VM types.
So if you need a VM
that has four times more
CPU and four times more
RAM than your current VM,
you're going to pay a rate
that is four times higher.
There's no penalty for
using a larger machine.
Things just scale
as they should.
So with these price
principles, we've
really taken the
guesswork out of pricing.
Your developers no longer have
to double as finance planners.
We do that for you.
You automatically get discounts
based on your actual sustained
usage without any commitments.
And that really was the
original dream of the cloud
that I talked about.
You have on demand capacity.
You pay for just what you need,
but you get a great price.
That is a world
that you can live in
as long as you use the
Google Cloud because that's
the experience
you'll have with us.
So now let's turn
to the other part
that makes cloud computing
harder than it could be.
And mostly it's that
you have to work around
certain limitations that
are in the cloud that
causes you to do extra work.
Let's look at a few of them.
First, just the basic
problem of time to market
versus scalability.
Should you build something
that is quick and works,
or should you make it scalable?
There's too many
examples of startups
that had to go rewrite
their back end just as they
were getting really popular.
It's a success
failure, essentially.
Second, flexibility
versus automation.
Do you want the flexibility
and the openness of VMs,
or do you want the automatic
management of App Engine?
And then third, big
data scalability
versus real time analytics.
Do you want to analyze really,
really large data sets,
or can you deal with
the special demands
of ingesting large
amounts of data
and analyzing them in real time?
And now fundamentally,
these are all hard problems.
But we want to make
the cloud easier,
and so we believe
that you should not
have to choose between
those apparent opposites.
We'd like to turn
this or into and,
and we'd like for you to be
able to do all of the above
in the same infrastructure.
And how we do that-- to
show you how we do that,
I'd like to call up
Greg DeMichillie.
Sorry, Greg.
He can't pronounce
my last name, I
can't pronounce his last name.
So I think we're about even.
So Greg, come up, and
Greg will explain to you
how we do all of this.
So Greg, all yours.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thanks, Urs.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Urs.
It's really no
exaggeration to say
that cloud is one of the
biggest trends that's
changing the way that
developers operate.
And with the new pricing
that Urs announced,
we really think that
this will be opened up
to even more developers
to take advantage
of the promise of the cloud.
Now before I deep dive
into those hard trade-offs
that Urs talked about, I
want to spend just a minute
and update you on a couple
of very common requests
I've heard from customers
since we met at I/O.
The first one's around
operating systems.
We know there's
customers out there who
want to run specific operating
systems because they have
workloads that depend upon
those operating systems.
So today we're announcing the
GA availability of both SUSE
and Red Hat Enterprise Linux
on the Google Cloud Platform.
So if you have workloads
that require either
of those products,
with one click
you can deploy virtual machines
using those two operating
systems.
But of course it's not
just a Linux world.
And one of the things we hear
a lot is, hey, Google, are you
really ever going
to support Windows?
And the answer to that's easy.
Our customers tell
us they want Windows,
so of course we're
supporting Windows.
So starting today, we
have a preview support
for the most popular version
of Windows Server out there
available on the cloud platform.
So if you're an
enterprise and you
have workloads that
depend upon Windows,
those are now open for
business on the cloud platform.
That's not the
only common request
that I've heard in
the months since we
were at I/O. Another one is
around network management.
We've heard from customers
that having to manage their DNS
infrastructure in one place and
managing their virtual network
configuration in another is a
pain to keep those up to date
and keep those in sync.
So today we're announcing
Google Cloud DNS.
An authoritative
DNS as a service.
Built, operated,
managed by Google.
Google scale, Google
reliability, with a simple API
and integrated into
the Google console.
So as a developer now, you
can manage your network
infrastructure for your
applications and your DNS
all in one place and get
very high performance,
easy to use DNS.
So those are a few of the
common requests that we've had.
Let me turn now to
those hard trade-offs
that Urs talked about.
Now the first one
we want to dive into
is around time to market
versus scalability.
So let's start at the beginning.
You're a developer.
Maybe you're at a startup,
maybe you're at an enterprise,
and you're building
an application.
Right away, you know that you
are going to be successful,
so of course you want
to build for scalability
so that when you go viral,
your application supports it.
But you've got a manager,
whether that's your manager,
or your board of directors,
or your stakeholder.
Somebody is telling you, get the
application out and get it out
yesterday.
So at some point you feel
this pressure to maybe
not spend as much
time on scalability
and really just
go with whatever's
the most productive
thing to build.
And then you pay the price.
The app goes viral,
suddenly your app is down,
and now you're
frantically trying
to rewrite the back end
while your customers are not
getting served.
We think that's a
false trade-off.
We think you should be able to
take advantage of the Google
scalability that we've built
the cloud platform around
from the beginning.
But you should also have a very
productive developer experience
to do it.
You shouldn't have to choose
between developer productivity
and scalability.
So to do that, we've been
focusing on a couple key areas.
One is making sure that when
you come to the cloud platform,
you can continue to
use the existing tools
and services that
you know and love.
Whether that's Git for your
source code repository,
or whether that's
Maven and Jenkins
for build and
continuous integration,
you should be able to continue
to use those tools and services
and have them integrate into the
cloud platform really nicely.
Second, when you
do a deployment,
you should have the confidence
to know that the deployment is
successful and that you didn't
have a bad deployment that
resulted in your
app not working.
And third, when problems
come up in production--
and they will come
up in production.
Because they never come up
in testing servers, right?
It's only production.
You should have the
ability to easily spot
those problems in production
and, with one click,
make fixes so that your
app is back on track
running like you want without
having to do a bunch of context
switching from the console
into a bunch of other tools.
So to give us a look at
exactly these things,
I want to bring up Brad Abrams.
He leads the product management
team for our developer
experiences group.
And he's going to give
us a demo of Zero to 60
in the Cloud Platform showing
these productivity features.
Brad?
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks, Greg.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: You need that?
BRAD ABRAMS: No,
I don't need it.
So in his copious
spare time, Greg's
been building out this cloud
event 2014 application.
But he ran into a
little snag, and he
asked me to use my programming
prowess to help him out.
So what we're looking at here
is the Google Developer Console
for Greg's application.
But before we drill into
the console, how many people
are command line fans?
How many people are more
productive on the command line?
Let's hear it.
OK.
Great, yes, me too.
So we're going to start there.
I'm going to show you our
new gcloud command line tool.
The reason I'm more
productive on the command line
is because of keyboard
shortcuts like Tab completion.
So I can just say
gcloud Tab, Tab.
And that shows me
the list of options
that are available there.
And then-- if I can type--
a Tab again completes that.
Oh yeah, and then what are
the options for components,
I can't remember?
Oh, right, list
is the one I want.
Tab finishes that out.
So pretty cool, huh?
OK.
Fine, OK.
So we have a set of
components that are available.
I can add and
remove those, but I
have what I think I need there.
So we'll clear that.
And I'll do another
gcloud command,
and we'll go ahead--
cloud event 2014--
we'll go ahead and bring
down code that Greg's already
started on to our
local workspace
so that we can get
started with this.
So let's take a look at
what Greg's already got.
I'm going to use my second
favorite editor here
to check out Greg's code.
And there, Greg, I think
I see your problem.
You forgot to give it a title.
So let's see if we can do that.
So GCP Live.
OK, just save that.
Now we're going to
use Git to commit that
to our local repository.
How many big Git fans
are there that use Git?
Yes?
Awesome.
So I'll do a Git commit.
And I'll say add a
title or whatever.
And then I'm going to go
ahead and do a Git push.
So when I did the gcloud init,
I initialized my local workspace
with a remote repository
that's hosted for us
in the Google Cloud.
And I've gone and
pushed that up.
So if we switch over
here to the console,
you'll see, when I refresh
this, that our new source code
viewer in the console has
that change that we looked at.
There it is.
GCP Live.
And now if I switch
over to releases,
we see this is the
Git URL that we
offer as part of every
developer console project.
You get a free
private Git repository
that's accessible to all the
members of your development
team on this project.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Now
that's really cool,
and a lot of people do use Git.
But a lot of people
also use GitHub,
whether it's for public
open source projects
or even for private repos.
So is there support
for that, too?
BRAD ABRAMS: Absolutely Greg.
At Google, we are
big fans of GitHub.
And so we've gone ahead
and added a Connect
to GitHub button,
so all the features
I'm going to show you
work great if you're
using a GitHub repository
or one of ours.
So regardless of which you
use, as a post commit action,
you have your choice
as to what happens.
We can do a build, run
a set of unit tests
before we deploy
that into production.
In this case, we've set
it to build with Maven,
run unit test, and then
deploy to our cloud platform.
To give you a peek inside a
little bit about what's really
happening, when we configured
that build, what we did
is we spin up a Compute
Engine instance.
And we installed on your
behalf half Jenkins, Maven,
JDK-- everything we needed
to do reliable builds.
And then when that
Git push happened,
we pulled down all the
code and did a clean build.
And then when that build passed,
we ran all your unit test
and then pushed
it to production.
So you can be more sure you get
a safe, reliable deployment.
And you can see, as I practiced
this demo, those spikes in the
build machines.
So if we switch back
over to cloud deployment,
you can see our release history.
And what you see here is
that we added that title,
we did a build test, and we
deployed that into production,
all in the time we've
been talking here.
So if we switch over
and see Greg's app.
Greg, it looks like a
little meme application.
That's kind of cool.
And it's going to
refresh with-- and we
see these-- here are
the memes you have.
Yes.
That's cute, petabytes of data.
And there's the
title that we added.
That's great.
I'm interested in what our top
memes are here at the cloud
event, so let's check those out.
Oh, Greg.
You have a server error here.
A 500 server error,
that's not good.
These kind of issues
are hard enough
to debug when it's on
your local machine.
But when you have an issue
like this in production,
it's even harder.
So to give you a sense about
debugging this in production,
I'm going to switch over and
give some simulated load.
So just going to throw a
lot of traffic at that site.
I saw some of you
copying down the URL,
so you might be throwing
some traffic at it as well.
So we'll go over and look
at how we debug that issue.
So I'm going to bring up
the new unified logs viewer.
And we're getting a log
entry for every request
that comes in.
And you saw, it just
threw a bunch of requests
at this thing.
And we're aggregating all those
logs across every front end
instance that we're spinning
up into a single unified view.
And so now I can just
scroll through here,
and notice as I'm scrolling,
it's loading new logs,
so it's easy for me to find the
logs that I'm interested in.
I can also filter these or, in
this particular place though,
I want to look for a status
500, because that's what we saw.
The 500 server error.
I can also come in and
filter by date and time.
So if I get a bug report
at a certain time,
I can narrow that
down pretty easily.
These filters can be chained
together with and and
or so you can get
exactly what you want.
OK, so here are the
errors that we're hitting.
And I can see, Greg,
the problem here
is in this ominously named
method, getMemes_Buggy.
Hmm.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: I had to make
it easy for you to find, Brad.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes,
I appreciate that.
So speaking of
finding that, you'll
notice the next thing we
want to do, as a developer,
is jump into the source.
Because that's where we're going
to be able to fix this problem.
But I have all this
context loaded in my head.
I need to get to
the source quick
so I can start
bringing that to bear.
So what I'm going
to do is notice
that right here, this
is actually a hyperlink.
So if I click right
on this hyperlink,
it brings me into the console,
into our source code view,
with exactly the version
of the source code that
was deployed into production and
that line of code highlighted.
Pretty useful?
[APPLAUSE]
So at this point, we can drop
back to get command line.
We could pull that file down
and start operating on it.
I can click on this
open in IDE button
and use a variety of third
party or Google-provided IDEs.
Or, because this is
a very quick change,
I can just click on Edit.
Make this change
right in the browser
and go ahead and do a commit.
And we'll just say
fix Greg's buggy code.
And we'll deploy
that into production.
Now how many of you have been
debugging a production issue,
and you ended up SSHing
into a production machine
and twiddling some config file
or messing with some PHP code.
Who's done that?
Yes, who's done
that this morning?
That's maybe not the best
idea, and that is not
what we're doing here.
We're actually committing
this change back
to the production
Git repository.
That change is attributed to me.
It's repeatable.
All future deployments will
have that code as well.
And we're running that
full release pipeline.
We're building the code
on a clean machine.
We're running all
our unit tests,
and we're deploying it only
if all those things pass.
Now, that takes a minute or
so for those things to happen,
so let's see if we can view
that deployment in progress.
So let's open that in a new tab.
And we should see
our new release.
There it is, we fixed
Greg's buggy code.
Notice it's already
built and tested
that in just this short time,
and we've deployed that out
into production.
So if we switch over
now and refresh this,
we should see the
top cloud memes.
And of course, they're
all Jeff Dean memes.
Guess that's how it goes.
So what you've
seen today is it's
very easy to use tools
you already know and love,
like Maven, Jenkins,
and Gradle to be
able to target our platform.
You've seen how
easy it is to get
reliable and quick deployments
with our new continuous
integration system.
And finally, you
saw how easy it was
to find and debug an
issue in production
and get that fixed quickly.
Thanks Greg.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thanks Brad.
That's really cool.
I think that'll help
a lot of developers
make the jump to the cloud
knowing that they can keep
using the tools that
they're comfortable with.
So let's turn to the second
of the big trade-offs,
and it's a big one.
Back in 2008, we
introduced App Engine,
which really became the
first widely used platform
as a service,
allowing developers
to focus only on the code that
make their application unique
and let us at Google handle
all of the stuff like scaling,
and management,
and configuration,
and let us carry a pager
so you don't have to.
But today you face
a tough choice.
Do I use products like
Compute Engine, infrastructure
as a service, that give me
total flexibility on open source
packages I use?
And operating systems and
programming languages.
But at the cost of me having
to carry my own pager,
scale my own infrastructure,
build out my own management?
Or do I use products like
App Engine, which free me
from all of that, but impose
certain restrictions on me?
Like they only let me
use certain languages
or certain environments.
This is another case of what
we think is a false dichotomy,
and it's one that
we want to address.
We think you should have access
to the languages and runtimes
you want and still get
the auto management,
auto capabilities of
products like App Engine.
So today we're introducing
managed virtual machines.
And managed VMs are
just what it says.
They are virtual machines
that run on Compute Engine,
but they are managed
on your behalf
with all of the
goodness of App Engine.
So this gives you a new way to
think about building services,
combining the
freedom and control
of App Engine--
of Compute Engine
with the capabilities
of App Engine.
So you can start with an
App Engine application,
and if you ever hit
a point where there's
a language you want to
use, or an open source
package you want to use
that we don't support,
with just a few
configuration line changes,
you can take part
of that application
and replace it with an
equivalent virtual machine.
And now you have control.
You can do whatever you
want, without giving up
all the benefits that you chose
App Engine for to begin with.
So to see this in
action, I've asked
Chris Ramsdale to come up.
Chris is going to give us a demo
of managed virtual machines.
He's going to take an
application like Brad used,
but he's going to add in now
C++ code and some open source
packages, while still keeping
the capabilities that he
thought App Engine was
great for to begin with.
So Chris, why don't you show
us managed virtual machines.
CHRIS RAMSDALE:
Cool, thanks Greg.
Appreciate it.
So what I want to
show you today is
how we use managed VMs to
take and add real time image
collaboration in the cloud
and add that to Brad's demo.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to have clients that are
running inside of Chrome that
are communicating back
with a fleet of managed
VMs via WebSockets, for
low latency communications.
And on these managed
VMs, we're going
to rely on ImageMagick,
a third party
open source library that's an
optimized C library for doing
image processing
and image rendering.
And we're going to use local
disks to cache the renderings,
make it super snappy.
And we're going to
use App Engine's Java
runtime as a serving
stack to get data flowing
from the front ends
to the back ends.
Now, as Greg alluded to,
that kind of technology
is not typically supported
on platforms as a service,
and not what App
Engine is today.
With managed VMs, this
is totally possible.
Furthermore, we make
it very easy to get up
and started with this.
So let me show you, we're going
to pop over to my terminal
here.
And what we see is a typical
App Engine configuration
file with a few parameters.
So we have an application,
we have a version,
we have what module's running.
With a few more lines
of configuration,
we're actually going to
turn this into a managed VM.
So let me walk through
these settings here.
So the first thing is
we're setting VM true.
That's telling the system I
want to run this on a managed VM
so I have access to native
resources and the ability
to run native code.
Furthermore, we get into a new
section called VM settings.
Here we specify machine
type, for example.
And since we're doing image
rendering and image processing,
we're going to crank up
the horsepower on these VMs
and deploy 8-core machines.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Now this could
be any of the Compute Engine
virtual machine types.
One, two, four,
eight, or more cores.
High mem, high CPU standard,
whatever's available in GCE,
you can use with
App Engine as well.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Absolutely,
Greg, and furthermore,
as we innovate here,
those innovations
will flow back to this
configuration as well.
The next line is the settings
for deploying the third party
code that I want on
those managed VMs.
In this case, we're using
ImageMagick and just
doing apt_get_install
to those managed VMs.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: And
again, anything installed
will be an apt_get
I can specify here,
and it becomes available
to me in a managed VM.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Absolutely.
This is how we're opening
up App Engine so you
can use third party
libraries like that
and get them onto those managed
VMs in a super simple way.
The next line is we're
opening up a port.
In this case, it's
an arbitrary port,
65080, and that's how we're
going to the WebSocket
communication from the clients
that are running in Chrome back
to those fleet of managed VMs.
And then for the
sake of this demo,
we're going to
specify two instances,
because that's more than
enough for this demo,
especially since we're
running 8-core machines.
So we're going to escape
from this, save it.
Now since we're running
in the Java runtime,
and it's a Java application, we
can use Maven to deploy this.
So while that's
running, I'm going
to talk about what's
happening under the hood, so
can we cut back to
the slides, please?
All right, the first
thing that's happening
is we're relying
on our gcloud tools
to parse and validate the
configuration file that I just
showed you.
Assuming that's
valid, which it is,
it's going to communicate
to our deployment endpoints
and say, OK, I want to
deploy this application.
Those deployment
endpoints are going
to store some metadata
about the application.
The version, the
template, the number
of instances that are running.
And then from there,
we're going to go off
and we're going to create
the actual containers.
In this case, we're creating
8-core Compute Engine VMs,
and we're installing our
Debian OS on top of that.
After that, we're going to
carve out the managed services
and make sure that everything's
lined up correctly for you.
So in this case, we're going
to do monitoring and health
checking, task queues,
memcache and data store.
We're also going to
create secure name spaces
so that everything is secure
within those multi-tenant
systems.
And we're going to
set up smart defaults
so it's very easy
to access the APIs
and get data flowing
back and forth.
From there, it's on
the serving stack.
And since we're running
on a Java runtime,
we're going to install a
web server, an application
server, and a JVM.
Then it's on to the
interesting parts, the parts
that you provide.
In this case, the third
party code that we specified,
so ImageMagick on
those managed VMs.
And then most
importantly, your code.
We're going to
bring all that up,
we're going to do
some health checking,
make sure everything's
running correctly.
And assuming it is, we're going
to install a load balancer,
and then we're going to
wire everything up for you.
The final step is we're
going to take all of that
and make sure it's colocated
with the other pieces
of compute that you're running.
So in this case,
Brad had showed you
some front ends
that were running.
We're going to take
the managed VMs
and colocate those
with your front ends
so you get low
latency and improve
the overall performance.
All right, so if we can
jump back to the demo.
All right, so our
build succeeded.
Let's go check
that out in Chrome.
So we'll pull this
up, we'll navigate
to the URL that's
provisioned for us.
All right, and there we
see our new front end.
Cloud Collabo,
collaboration in the cloud.
This is pretty straightforward.
We're going to be able
to upload an image,
we're going to do some
edits to that image.
Those edits are going to be
shared with the people that
are collaborating
and then we're going
to do some real time
conversation back and forth.
So let's pick an image.
Meme two looks good.
All right.
Man of the hour,
Urs, we're going
to use his meme to
actually get going.
So that's uploading to
cloud storage right now.
All right, there it is.
So it's uploaded.
We see that I am the
only collaborator,
so let's change that.
I'm going to share
this with Greg.
Now demo note where I'm going to
use Chrome profiles to simulate
Greg and myself
communicating back and forth.
So we're going to bump
over to Greg's profile.
Oh yes, it looks
just like you, Greg.
Oh, you're a Despicable
Me fan as well.
I love it, it's great.
That is like the craziest theme
I've ever seen in my life.
All right, back to business.
OK, so I'm sharing this
with Greg right now.
It's going out.
It's going to log him in.
Wait for it.
OK, there he is.
All right, and you see
now that Greg and I
are collaborating on this image.
Now to show you it
happening in real time--
I'm going to try to
move this over here.
So I'm going to pretend
that Greg is actually
doing the editing, and you're
going to see things happening
if everything works correctly
in my browser as well.
So we'll dress up
with a frame first.
Nothing goes with
green like magenta.
Grab that.
Say Add Border.
Good, we've got a border.
And now we're going to add
some high-end doodling.
Now somebody had mentioned
that doodling on Urs's image
is probably a
career-ending move.
But I said hey, why not?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Only
if the demo doesn't work.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Ha ha, exactly.
All right, so we're going
to give Urs a big smile.
Good prices in cloud.
His famous earring,
a little more bling.
There we go.
And now we see that it's
happening in real time
back to my browser.
And so again,
what's happening is
that these two clients,
connecting over WebSockets
backed the managed VMs.
We're doing the rendering,
were caching in a local disk.
Then we're sending the updates
back to the Chrome clients.
Now I want to take a second
and say to all the App Engine
developers and users
that are in the crowd
that this typically
wasn't, and was not
supported in App Engine.
But yet it's been a top feature
request consistently year
over year.
So I'm happy to announce that
those feature requests are
now fixed and available to you.
OK, so it's not just about--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, all the App
Engine developers in the crowd.
So while the ability to
access native resources
and run native code on these
managed VMs is fantastic,
it's not just about that.
It's about great developer
experiences and great developer
integration.
So to show you that, I'm
going to bump back out
to the developer's console here.
Over here.
OK.
It's the same UI that
Brad had shown previously.
It's our developer's console.
And I'm going to show how
we've integrated App Engine
and Compute Engine by drilling
down into the App Engine tab.
We see our dashboard,
we see our modules.
I'm going to select our
back end module, that's
the one that's handling
all the real time
collaboration and communication.
We'll drill into the instances.
And here we'll see
the instances that
are running for my application.
So, remember back in
the configuration file,
we specified that we
want two managed VMs.
Here we see those, and if we
drill into this VM over here.
Give it a second.
OK.
And so there's the dashboard
for the underlying VM.
If we move down
the page, you can
see that it is, in
fact, an 8-core machine.
We've automatically configured
an external IP for it.
And there's some
metadata here that
allows us to manage the VM,
quite a bit of it actually.
So that's drilling
down into the VM.
Now let's bubble
back up and see how
we've integrated all
the managed services.
We come back to
the App Engine tab.
We'll go to our
unified logs viewer.
Now what's nice about this
is it's not just unifying
the logs on all my managed VMs.
It's actually unifying
the logs across all the
compute that I'm doing, be it a
front end running on App Engine
or managed VMs that are running
on top of Compute Engine VMs.
So here we see that there's
a fair number of servlets
that are being hit
for my back end.
Got one for serving
up an image, one
for creating a
WebSockets connection.
And while you could do all of
this on an unmanaged VM-- you
could do it on a raw
Compute Engine VM,
you can deploy
syslog or rsyslog.
We think there's a
more productive way.
We think that by offering a
managed and centralized service
like this, you can become a
more productive developer.
And furthermore, if you
apply that philosophy out
to things like authentication,
deployment management,
configuration management,
developer tools,
developer console,
that you can be
a more productive and happier
developer for the cloud.
Now let's take a look at
how-- speaking of developer
productivity, let's
take a look at what
we do with the underlying VMs.
Now, we had mentioned that these
VMs are locked down by default.
So they're not-- you
don't have root access.
You don't have SSH
axis into them.
And that's for good reason.
We don't want people going out
into production making changes
to one of those VMs
that are running inside
of a large fleet.
It makes it hard to manage
within a high availability
manner.
But we recognize
the fact that there
are times when you need
to get to those VMs
to do things like do
some kind of debugging
or check on a configuration
file that you have,
or make some
configuration change just
to see what happens
to the underlying VM.
We make that super
simple as well.
So we come back here
to the terminal.
We're going to do
a gcloud instances.
Excuse me, gcloud
compute instances list.
And there's our two VMs
that are actually running.
And now we're going to enable
debugging for one of those.
So I'm goingn to do
gcloud compute debug--
use the local
directory, which has
the configuration for
these managed VMs.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to go through that
deployment end point
and put those two managed
VMs into debug mode, which
is what you're seeing here.
I'll clear that up.
If we do gcloud
compute instances.
List again, so I can
get the-- grab the name,
let's grab the first one.
We'll SSH into that.
Let's grab that guy.
Instead of list, we'll do SSH.
OK.
And now that'll SSH us
into the underlying VM,
what you see here--
cramsdale@ae-backend-1-0.
Clear that up.
Now once we're on this VM, we
have access to common tools
you would normally use
on a virtual machine.
In this case, we can do
things like run netstat.
We see all the
activity that's running
through the various
connections on the VM.
In this case, we can actually
see up there at 65080,
the port we're listening on for
the WebSockets communication.
Then we can do
things like interact
with the Debian
package [INAUDIBLE]
and see that the package
that we specified inside
of the configuration file
is actually on the VM.
In this case, we'll do DPKG, and
we'll do a grep for, let's say,
magick.
And sure enough, there you
see that on the bottom right,
you'll see that our package is
actually installed on the VM.
And so all we need
to do is we exit.
We'll seal that VM back up,
and things are going to go.
So what we've seen here
is that with managed VMs,
we can take advantage
of the auto management
that App Engine provides with
the control and flexibility
of underlying
Compute Engine VMs.
We make it super
simple to get started
with easy configuration,
easy deployments,
integration back with
managed services,
as well as integration
with our developer
console and our developer tools.
So that you don't have
to make a choice between,
oh, I want platform as a
service and automanagement,
or I want to choose flexibility
with Compute Engine.
Managed VMs brings
both of those together,
giving you the best
of both worlds.
So with that, I'm going to
turn it back over to Greg.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thanks Chris.
[APPLAUSE]
So there you really
saw the ability
to blend auto management and
flexibility in one offering.
We think that's going to be
a great way for developers
to be more productive.
So the last hard problem that
we want to talk about today
is a big one.
It's all about data.
Big data is really
revolutionizing the way people
deal with analytics.
And companies are
able to get insights
from data that was
never before possible,
it was previously
just sort of a mass
of data they couldn't
make sense of.
But if you take a look at
most big data deployments,
there's a lot of
work in those that
has nothing to do
with analytics.
It's about moving
data from A to B,
or sharding it so
it's efficient.
Or transforming it from
one format to another.
None of which is
actually about analyzing.
It's all about setting
up so you can analyze.
What you really want
to be able to do
is take data as it's
generated in its raw form,
ingest it in real time
as it's being generated,
and start analyzing it the
minute it's in your system
without having to go through
intermediate warehousing
and transformation steps.
And that's really why
we first built BigQuery.
BigQuery, you probably
know, builds on a tool
that we developed
internally at Google.
Early on at Google,
we realized that we
had to find a way
to look at the log
files of massive numbers
of front end web servers
to see what's going on.
And we knew that none of the
existing data tools out there
would be anywhere close enough.
So we built an
internal tool for that,
and BigQuery is
built on top of that.
So it uses the
same technology we
use to do massive data analytics
of front end web servers,
but with a very friendly
SQL-like syntax.
So back in September,
we introduced
in BigQuery a streaming API.
And BigQuery streaming
allowed you to take data
as you're generating
it, whether that's
from applications or
from physical devices.
Send it into
BigQuery, and as soon
as you send it to
BigQuery, it shows up
and is available for analysis.
Well, we started
out allowing you
to ingest 1,000 rows per
second into BigQuery.
Today, we're taking
that to the next level.
We're announcing
BigQuery streaming
supporting 100,000 rows
per second of ingestion.
So what that means is you can
take massive amounts of data
that you generate.
And as fast as you can generate
them and send it to BigQuery,
you can start analyzing it and
drawing business conclusions
from it without setting
up data warehouses,
without building charting,
without doing ETL,
without doing copying.
So to give you a demo of
exactly that, of real time
large amounts of data
being analyzed in BigQuery,
I have a special guest
we want to bring up.
I want to bring up Eric Schmidt.
Not the chairman of the board
of directors Eric Schmidt,
the Eric Schmidt from
the Cloud Platform team.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thanks, Greg.
I'm a solutions architect
in the Cloud Platform team,
not the chairman of the board.
In this demo, I
want to demonstrate
how you can leverage
BigQuery to do near real time
interactive analysis over
rapidly changing massive data
sets.
Now as Greg just
talked about, we now
have the ability to ingest
100,000 rows per second,
per table, into BigQuery.
For this demo, I'm
modeling some use cases
from a company
called Glen Canyon.
Glen Canyon is a
pioneer in smart meter
and intelligent network
technology for electric power
utilities.
They have millions of
meters in the market today.
This is an example
of one of them.
They communicate
over Wi-Fi and 3G.
For our demo, we're going to
have these meters report out
once a minute, 60
events an hour,
and I'm going to
virtualize these meters
over the city of
Seattle, which roughly
has 400,000 meters
in its network.
At the end of the
day, we're going
to be processing around 17
billion events per month.
Flip over to the demo machine.
All right.
So the first thing I
want to do is just dive
into a couple very,
very simple queries
to give you some
context about what's
happening with the system.
On my other machine over
here, this is my meter system.
I'm generating load to
create hundreds of thousands
of meter requests.
This query here I'm just
going to do a quick count
from my single table that I'm
doing raw ingestion of records.
I apologize to all my
DBA friends out there
for doing a select star
with no where clause.
So there you go.
We have over 4.6 billion
rows in this table.
We're doing around a
half billion per day.
So this is roughly a little
over a week's worth of data.
So what does this
data look like?
If I go and look at
my raw data table.
Scroll down.
First get details.
And you can see down at the
bottom I have individual meter
ID, the read time from
the meter, its status--
the status is very important.
How many of you had to
call the electric company
to tell them that
your power's off?
Wouldn't it be great whenever
you call them, they tell you?
You have active energy,
this is how many
kilowatts per hour the home
or businesses is drawing.
And if I scroll
all the way out, I
have things like the actual
temperature of the meter.
So temperature
increases of a meter
typically indicate some
type of mechanical failure.
And finally, you have
the insertion time,
the time that the
record was actually
inserted into BigQuery.
This record, on a case-by-case
basis, is 128 bytes.
So roughly, we're building
around two terabytes per month
just for the
simulation of Seattle.
But if you want to put
this into perspective,
you start multiplying the
number of cities on the planet,
you're talking about hundreds
and hundreds of terabytes
into petabytes.
So what can we do
with this data?
I'm going to flip over.
I'm going to rerender this.
This is a real
time visualization
of all the meters in
Seattle, all 400,000.
This visualization is
powered by a standing query
that I'm running
that will calculate
all of the average power
for the entire grid.
So you can see this
mean energy that's
being drawn across the screen.
It's a sliding window of
approximately 10 minutes.
So every second, I'm
streaming on average
around 8,000 to 10,000
records into the system
because I have it
completely distributed.
And BigQuery is constantly
ingesting and enabling
me to query that
data in real time.
Now, let's go ahead
and zoom in and try
to find a location because
it's kind of hard to see what's
going on in this map
with so many points.
So I'm going to find my
local coffee shop on 19th.
Fuel Coffee.
If you've ever been in Seattle,
they have great coffee.
I'm going to go ahead
and rerender this map,
and in the background, I
have run another query that
is doing geographic
analysis just
on the lat and long
boundary for all the points
that are in this view.
So if I start
clicking on them, I
can go ahead and get
some details specifically
about just this meter.
The interesting thing here to
point out is I have one table.
One single table for me
to do my aggregations
that I just showed you in the
previous graph or these graphs
that are looking at
specific atomic records.
The active energy as well
as the temperature, so we
can go ahead and click around.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: And this also
shows how BigQuery is not only
for interactive analysis,
but you can actually
build applications that
sit on top of BigQuery
to do visualizations at
the API level as well.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Exactly,
so some of the queries
that I'm about to show you that
I was using in the console.
Those are running inside of
a set of Python application
as well as a Java application
to power this visualization.
All right, let's get back
and look at some queries.
This query is the
average power by time.
And I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
This is fundamentally
the same query
that was powering the overall
averaging of an entire system.
Now, you'll note here, up top
where, in my from statement,
I'm using a relatively new
feature inside of BigQuery
called table decorators.
What this enables you to do is
basically filter down the rows
that you would like to
see that have been written
into a particular table
in a given time window.
So fundamentally, I've taken
four plus four billion rows
and narrow it down
to roughly 800,000.
This helps with
query performance
as well as reduce query cost.
So you can view table
decorators as a simplified where
with some benefits.
So there you go, there's the
average of the entire system
right now.
Around 5.7 kilowatts an hour.
This is interesting.
I can do real time-- near real
time-- interactive analysis
over lots of data.
But let's write a bigger
query, because after all, this
is BigQuery.
This query is the
basis for the query
that I was running
whenever I was zooming in
on my geocoordinates.
And one of the things I
want to point out here--
Urs talked about
this this morning--
released a feature last fall
called join, or Big JOIN.
In this case, what
I'm doing is I
am joining my raw meter table,
those four billion rows,
to a metadata table that
contains all of my lat
and long information
for my meters.
This is a great way to maintain
normalization in your database.
I'm a big NoSQL fan as well,
but one of the challenges
is you end up
muddying your tables
with lots of redundant data.
Well, with the power of
join, I can go ahead and just
filter out, given lat
and long, the meter
IDs that I would like
to address in my query.
So I'm roughly filtering
down to a couple
hundred inside of that view.
And I'm averaging and also
looking at their status
to see if they're off and on.
It's fundamentally the same
query I was running before,
except I'm using joins to
filter out lat and long.
Now I can average-- so I have
roughly, probably 200 to 300
in this view-- and
I'm averaging so I
can see who's the
highest user-- I
do a sort at the bottom of this
query-- I want to see who's
the highest user of
power on average.
The other thing I
did in this query
is leverage cross joins and
the statistical function
called quantiles.
To look at the entire 400,000
meters that are in this system
and look at the
quantile distribution--
I have 100 steps in
this distribution--
so that I can compare an
individual meter to the entire
population .
So I'm fundamentally
taking four billion rows,
narrowing it down to
around 800, doing a join,
and then doing a quantile back
on the entire grid system.
That's a big query.
But you'll notice
I only processed
around 200 megabytes of data.
I didn't process
gigs of data, and I
did this in roughly 15 seconds.
So there you go,
meter number 163, 236.
They are the highest average
user in that geo grid.
And, ironically, they're
also in the 99th quantile
because my data is all
completely randomized,
but it's randomized
with the same patterns.
Now, this same type of
query, you might not even
have been able to
run this if you're
running in a NoSQL environment.
Or, if you didn't have
the processing power,
you may have gone to
lunch and then came back.
Right?
So, I have one more
query to show you.
While I've been running
this demo on my machine
over here-- just making sure
that our system is still up--
instead of running the
system to report every 60
seconds or every minute, I've
asked the system the report
out roughly every seven
seconds Functionally,
I've taken 400,000
meters and turned them
into 2.8 million meters.
This equates to roughly
around 45,000 rows
per second being
ingested into my table.
Not doing any sharding.
I have one table to do
all of my analysis off of.
Now if you needed to do
further RPS, you could shard.
And you could do use
something like wild cards.
And you could get
hundreds of thousands,
or millions of rows per
second, into BigQuery.
So there you have it.
All of your data in
one common environment.
You have a friendly
SQL-like syntax.
You have high throughput,
low latency ingestion,
to do near real time
interactive analysis
at democratized pricing.
So thanks for your time, I hope
you enjoy the rest of the show.
Please turn off your
lights, and go big data.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG DEMICHILLIE: It
just blows my mind
that while Eric was
doing that demo,
that we were putting in
45,000 new rows per second
while he's doing the demo live.
He gets like the gutsy on
stage demo award for the day,
I think.
When you look at
everything we're doing,
this is a great time
to be a developer.
We're going to have
drill-down sessions
on all of these technologies
throughout the day as well
as product managers
and engineers
to help you answer
your questions.
So with that, I'm going
to turn things back over
to Urs to sort of
wrap up, and thank
you very much for your time.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you, Greg.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thanks, Urs.
URS HOLZLE: All right.
Well as Greg said, this
truly is an exciting time
to be engineer.
Because you can
build an application
for a global
audience, and you have
to do very little to
do that other than
focus on your problem.
That is our goal.
The amount of change
and innovation around us
that's happening right
now is really incredible.
And that creates a
huge opportunity.
And what we want to do is
build the Cloud Platform
that you want to use to take
advantage of that opportunity.
So really, a lot of
what we focused on today
was productivity and how do
we make you more productive
in developing in the cloud.
Make it easier to build and
test and deploy in a cloud using
the tools that we already know.
And then with
managed VMs, you're
going to have the
flexibility of App Engine--
sorry, the automanagement
of App Engine
with the flexibility of VMs.
And you don't have to
choose between the two.
And then as we
just saw, BigQuery
allows you to make big
data analysis really just
work at any scale.
You don't have to choose
between really high scale,
interactive querying,
or real time data.
All of this, all these three
things, you get on one tool,
one single tool on the
Google Cloud Platform.
And on top of
that, of course, we
have made this all
more affordable
than it's ever been before,
by following Moore's Law.
Because we believe that the
price of virtualized hardware
should follow the same
trends that the price
of real hard work follow.
Really, Moore's Law
is here to stay,
and you will see
that in our cloud.
Now on top of that,
I have shown you
how you can get additional
discounts for sustained usage.
But without upfront
payments, without locking,
without long term commitment,
and really without the planning
hassle that you have to go
into with other providers just
to get a good price.
So this is really a new way of
thinking about pricing I think.
A way where we move the
planning hassle from you to us
so that you can
focus on the things
that you actually
want to focus on.
So everything we're doing
with the platform, really,
is about making you
more productive.
And helping you,
the developer, to do
the things you love
and let us do the rest.
So, we introduced a
lot of things today.
But it's just March.
So you can look forward to
a lot more later this year.
And I'll certainly see
many of you at Google I/O
here in San Francisco in June,
when we will have a lot more
to say about the Google Cloud.
But before we get
there, we're going
to go on a tour, a
developer roadshow,
starting two weeks from
now, going through 27 cities
worldwide.
So look for that at
cloud.google.com/roadshow,
and I hope to see some
of you there as well.
So with that, enjoy
the rest of the day.
All the detailed sessions.
Thank you for putting
your applications
in the Google Cloud.
Thank you for attending
Cloud Platform Live.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]